هذا ليس خطًا للطعام أو الماء ، لكنهم
لا يزالون يقولون إنها ضرورة مجردة في
فنزويلا ، فهم يائسون حتى من أجل
عرض تحديد النسل للشرب لعدة
سنوات الآن عدة مرات في الأسبوع يأتون
إلى العيادة الصحية - إنهم بعض
من الوحيدين  تحديد النسل
متوفر وكنت مثل مرة أخرى ،
إنه أمر مروع ، جونا ، أخبرني أنه
لا يمكنك الحصول على وسائل منع الحمل إذا حصلت
عليها ، وتضيف صديقتها إميلي أنها
باهظة الثمن حتى لو كنت تعمل ،
لا يكفي راتبك الكامل للحصول على واحدة  عبوة من
الحبوب ، وبالنسبة للفتيات الصغيرات اللواتي لا يستطعن الحصول على وسائل منع الحمل ، يخبرونني ، وخ
صة ال
راهقات ، أن الكثير منهم يتجهون إلى الإجهاض ، نرى أننا زر
ا مع المدير الطبي للعيادة من
أشهر والوضع هو
فسه اليوم ، وهو يؤكد أن وس
ئل منع الحمل نادرة في ال
يادات ال
امة و  تقول منظمة الصحة العالمية إن
فنزويلا لديها الآن واحدة من أعلى
معدلات حمل المراهقات في أمريكا الجنوبية ،
حيث أن
وسائل منع الحمل في السوق السوداء باهظة الثمن للغاية  بالنسبة
لمعظم وعواقب هذا
النقص تشكل خطرًا أكبر على
صحة النساء والفتيات على المدى الطويل.
كنت خائفة اعتقدت أنني
سأموت لأن هناك الكثير من
الدماء وكان
نزيفًا مروعًا ، ذهبت لرؤية طبيب
لكنها لم تستطع الاعتراف بإجراء عملية
إجهاض وما زالت لا تريد
الكشف عن هويتها.
الإجهاض غير قانوني في فنزويلا
يعاقب عليه حتى  سنتان في
السجن ، هناك طريقة لمعرفة ما
يفعلونه وكيفية إجرائهم لعمليات
الإجهاض ، لذلك من
المقلق جدًا أن تقول هذه الناشطة النسائية
أن أحدث السجلات الصحية المتاحة
تظهر أن معدل وفيات الأمهات في فنزويلا
ارتفع بنسبة 60٪ في عام 2016 وحده دراسة حديثة  من
وفيات الأطفال ، كما تقول ،
تم العثور على الأجنة في صناديق القمامة أو
تم التخلي عن الأطفال ، وقد فوجئنا حقًا
بالعدد الهائل
وهذه الأرقام الموجودة على  التي وصلت إلى
وسائل الإعلام ، لا نعرف عدد
النساء اللاتي يعشن الآن في خوف من كيف يمكن
للنشاط الجنسي والحمل أن يقلب
صحتهن وحياتهن فقط في سي إن إن
كاراكاس